[Applause]
I think I'm getting the hang of this
what do you think guys
our next guest is a writer comedian and
legend in the making her show zeeway
will have you squirming thinking deep
and laughing out loud at the same time
take a look where do you stand on the
Emancipation Proclamation I am for
freedom is that the right answer can you
tell me Drew
but wait what was the question
what's more differs the cast of Glee or
the Supreme Court
foreign
[Music]
is that because you're not used to
listening
as an Italian American would you
consider yourself a person of color no
definitely not although although
please welcome Z-Wave
hi
thank you for having me Curtis hey you
look great is this our first time
meeting you know I I think it is our
first time meeting but I like I have
vivid images of like the club so maybe
I've seen you in passing I checked out
your Instagram and I saw you met uh
Megan Marco yes how was that she it was
a pleasure she is so interesting and so
fascinating we had a Northwestern
connection we went to the same college
so it was really cool to be on her
podcast and talk about stereotypes
you're born and raised in Massachusetts
yes I'm born and raised in Massachusetts
oh was that it was
iconic it was really Massachusetts is
such a strange place because it's so
cold but they constantly remind you
about the union and the Confederacy so
it's a lot of learning most of the time
I'd say how was it growing up in Queens
oh man it's uh it was pretty rough
in the beginning but I know you're from
Nigeria right yeah
are you making a movie about Nigerians
or a TV show yes about Adrian scammers
yeah yeah yes my parents are Nigerian
I'm not a scammer I am I'm an
intellectual
but they're going to be very excited
that I'm talking to the 50 Cent when I
was a kid they actually Banned Me from
listening to your music
I don't remember the massacre you
remember like get rich or die trying so
I would I had a Walkman I would just
turn it up and I would come in my room
alone no I was listening to VeggieTales
instead yeah
yeah sure knows no limits and you aren't
afraid this is obvious what makes you
like uh so gutsy that's
it the gutsy unit
so I think what makes me so brave is
being able to have a strong perspective
and standing by it that's kind of what I
like about your Instagram you you like
you're not afraid to say whatever's on
your mind and then yeah
okay
it's honestly brave for men to Double
Down
but when you say the wrong thing you
better not double down you it was
canceled so quick you you see what
happened to Kanye
cancellation or self-cancellation but
but I guess in my show right
[Applause]
I I like you because you Barrel towards
controversy head first I do I just know
when I'm I'm in the wrong area I can
feel when things start getting dangerous
do you have any questions for me I have
a hundred questions for you
my first question for you did you did
you have any idea that you'd go on to
host the Drew Barrymore show
I had no idea that I would be hosting
the Drew Barrymore show and I was like
yo you know this is my big break
you know I don't
know you know and I'm just excited I'm
just happy to be here I love that I love
that my question is how do you get like
what number in the call sheet are you
was you were you the first call yeah I
actually became I am Drew Barrymore at
the present moment so I'm number one on
this show right now technically I'm
filling in for number one see that's why
these people treat me so good
and since you are Drew Barrymore what is
your best Drew Barrymore impression to
camera please I thank you very much no
nobody prepped me to perform I didn't
have to come to that part like did it
did it tell me I had to perform as Drew
Barrymore you try to you put pressure on
me she has a Golden Glove I would never
dare do that
just say I love rain just say I love
rain
wow
wow
and I just love to imagine you sort of
like watching Drew Barrymore movies
what's your favorite one uh Charlie's
Angels Charlie's Angels
[Applause]
can you do the pose do the pose
I'm in the middle so they're doing that
around me
[Applause]
you know but um before I let you go I'm
putting you in the hot seat okay so I'm
actually the final five yes
I'm gonna ask you five rapid questions
Yeah question one what's your favorite
candy
and have you ever been to the candy shop
I can't believe I said that although
what do you what are your comedic
influences is the show of rest of
development have you ever been arrested
I've never been arrested you said that
you want people to know that you found a
boy and eat your own human yes you
believe in aliens I feel like I'm I've
been abducted by aliens right now yeah
they're just Bright Lights I'm talking
to 50 Cent I'm not sure this is reality
this is very good which one of us do you
think is better hosting the shop I think
that we're separate but equal
explain you said you were discipline the
school for asking too many questions yes
how would you discipline me
no you guys feel this no no
no it's actually a regular question it's
a regular question I'm just asking how
you would you know don't get carried
away now
I just asking a simple question like you
ask people all kind of crazy questions
and they have to answer it because it's
just show and now you're on the Drew
Barrymore show on technically it's my
show because I'm running this show
[Applause]
thank you
shut down
the showtime at November 18th and on
cable November 20th
[Music]